hey everybody it's mike from overflows
and welcome to today's video you know
today is uh what is it tuesday september
13th 2022 cpi just came in this morning
uh every measure came in worse than
anticipated month to month it was still
up uh was that like point one percent
you know the core is worse by point six
percent year on year we're back up to uh
eight point three
and uh honestly i think uh we got a fed
meeting on the was it the 21st you know
we're gonna see if they're going to go a
full point or three quarters of a point
and you know
market sold off quite sharply right on
the number we dropped like 100 points or
so more or less on uh the release of the
number and on the order flow you know it
was a lot of zeros you know the market
the liquidity just vaporized it was just
removed out of the market you could see
basically from 56 and three quarters all
the way down to you know what is that 44
and three quarters there was nothing
zero transactions there was no liquidity
in the market
gone you know no no everyone's just
pulling their bid you know it's it's
funny you know i saw something on
you know facebook you know one of these
futures trading groups you know people
posted a picture of the of the bar that
came out and oh this is why you got to
use a stop well no you know
bars like this
on the cpi are reasons not to trade the
market be in the market when the number
is coming out you know the smart traders
they pull their bids they pull their
offers they don't want to get caught
offsides um you know for a number that
can potentially be bad
okay and you know we literally gave up
all the gains that we had over the last
week
you know it was like last week everyone
saw the bear market's in we're down 10
percent and then we recovered it this
past week now we're down you know in one
day back uh gosh where are we trading
right now 30
you know 39.50
you know 39 50s right now
when earlier this morning we're trading
you know 4150s so you know there's a big
200 point drop there now what was
interesting in the delta right you could
see obviously as this market is selling
off delta's going down but market kept
selling off and delta cumulative delta
was rising actually got from a very
negative reading of you know minus 10
000 back up to zero
before you know falling over again and
we're back down you know below 10 000
again
and you know what i want to talk about
today is you know some of the ways to
spot a market under strong selling
pressure with order flow now yeah you
know
we did have the very bearish number that
came out so obviously the market was
going to be under
duress
pretty much all day
and
they're what i'm going to talk about is
is some
things you could look for when
you know we don't have these big
economic numbers coming out just sort of
in in the regular trading session you
know sort of normal days um you could
look for this as well not just on days
you know that are very
big down days i mean obviously we're
down big down you don't want to be
buying necessarily but um what i want
so i'm going to get into it here let's
go back to uh when once the cash opened
at 8 30. now again you know this is an
easy way to spot market under strong
selling pressure
obviously
the bearish number
is leading up to it but really what you
want to be looking at is a market that's
being driven by
longer term traders right not
necessarily the the the short-term
traders you know the intraday traders
but really sort of you know people
coming in and
almost getting out of their positions
you know
i don't necessarily say adding shorts
but at least getting out
and
it's pretty obvious in the order flow
when you know
what to look for so again you know
nine o'clock we started rallying right
in terms of cumulative delta even though
you know the market dropped from you
know 40 25
all the way down to you know below 3 900
here i mean
when cumulative delta got above zero
we're trading you know 4008 but that's a
good you know almost uh 30 point drop
you know to its low while cumulative
delta was was going up
and what's that telling you
well if you're looking at uh
let me see which charts do i want to
pull up if
you know on a simple order flow chart it
might be a little bit difficult for some
people to read
again i spent some time talking about a
delta footprint let me just go back here
to around
eight o'clock and you know one of the
things that i spent the last few days
talking about
is this but it's sort of in the opposite
because the market had been rallying but
now what we're seeing is a market
making new lows
red bar red bar red bar red bar
with positive delta
yes what the [__] mike you're telling me
markets go up on positive delta markets
sell off on negative delta now we're
pounding down into new lows
on positive delta make up your mind well
okay the reason it's doing that is
because you have strong sellers coming
in here and by strong sellers
notice i didn't put
passive or aggressive in there these are
strong
passive sellers you do have aggressive
sellers
now we're at lowe's of the day so
obviously there's always going to be
people interested in buying off the lows
of the day you know that's how some
people are are trained to trade you know
we're at the lows of the day you look
for reasons to buy i like to look for
reasons to buy however if i see strong
offers coming in
to absorb all that selling
right you can see here this is at 936
let's let's take a look at
the regular footprint right in here okay
might be a little bit hard to notice
obviously the first sign is going to be
the positive deltas right down in here
but if you're looking in here
at the footprints
what do you see
well you see the volumes the heavier
volumes
are being traded on the offer side 426
versus 176 at the price of 16 and a
quarter
634 versus 502 at a price of 15 and
three quarters
sorry that was
4016 the price then at 15 and three
quarters you can see 381 versus 479 even
in the next bar 62 against 108 89
against 220 92 against
208 right even in the next bar 73
against 241.
so you're seeing you know as the market
is making these new lows you're seeing
sellers come in offering it out they
have supply they want to get rid of you
know
when we're at lowe's of the day and you
got a lot to sell you just don't go in
and start hitting all the bids
that's a great time to offer it out
right i mean yeah are you gonna put your
foot on top of the market you know maybe
but if we're at the lows of the day
chances are maybe there's some buyers
down there there's some bottom fishers
down there and they're coming in that is
why this market is going lower on
positive delta even down in here look at
this
big positive delta one thousand
thirty five one zero three five look at
the next bar positive delta six ninety
six these are red candles going lower
look at this bar right here
1059 you got a buying imbalance here 248
against
horizontal delta 320 versus one zero
five nine this is it on the on the
footprint where are we here
you know you see this big 739
up here you got 402 403 even up here you
got you know 102.
so what you have is you have sellers
coming in
sort of act giving resistance overhead
resistance to this market you know
they're happy to to sell out they got a
lot to sell
on a market that's going down and when
you start seeing that
sort of i don't know how to just what
the proper term is right now i can't
think
you know it's like
supply coming into the market but it's
coming in at lower levels you wouldn't
normally think of supply coming into the
market at lower levels but this is what
it looks like when people just you know
big traders want to get out of positions
market is selling off you don't want to
start chasing it you're happy to trail
it down you know you're happy to you
know if this market is making new lows
here at 40
you know 0.506 in here and you know
you've got
a couple thousand to sell
you know you work some up here at eights
at seven and a halfs at sevens you know
sixes
you piece it in right you just don't go
in and just hit every bid clear out the
order book no you want to keep offering
it out offering it out so that
when the market does bounce back up
you're gonna get filled
and that way you're not influencing the
market so much
because
you're not just clearing out the order
book
okay and then you know all these people
that are sitting there watching the dome
you know don't see your big order
clearing out the order book
maybe you know most people would
probably hide the size if you're a big
trader but the smaller
um
what do you want to call it you know
a hundred lots isn't gonna you know
scare anybody 200 probably not going to
scare anybody today the volume was very
uh robust in my opinion you know you're
seeing bars this is a one minute chart
you're seeing um very good volumes come
in you know six and a half thousand five
thousand five thousand pretty consistent
all right pretty consistent
as this market is
going down
okay now
the next part i want to talk about is
sort of like i think it's around 1 30
not too long ago um just let me find it
here on the chart real quick
here's around 130. okay so here we go um
again on the bar chart just you know for
quick reference if you just expanded a
bit
130s you know obviously we're coming
down in here taking out the lows and you
see this nice big drop where it just
sort of fell off the cliff
over you know from basically 130 to the
tooth to you know 2 30. it dropped about
you know where were we trading here you
know we're trading around 90 um you know
we dropped down you know towards 50
in an hour and
again some what are the signs in the
order flow obviously
make that new low you got that nice
stacks sun and balance there but as
you're coming in here okay so you see
these point controls right around the
same level more or less you got three at
the same price than the next three right
at the same price
but what you're seeing right that i was
pointing out earlier in terms of the
delta at price look at this big volumes
223 529 393 131 126 there's strong
offers coming in there right now if
you're looking at a normal footprint
chart maybe you can pick it up you know
for me the clear sign was you know this
market was sort of rotating you know
over these um what is that six bars with
point of controls more or less the same
price again people say well you got
three here three here yeah i could
average them together and it would be um
39 92 and and spot three seven five
and then you see the market whereas it
starts trading below comes right back up
to those levels where
these pointed controls are i mean you
can just draw that line when you see a
lot of point of controls coming in at
the same levels
just sort of visualize it draw it
right and then you're trading below it
this is going to be a potential
resistance area market trader right back
up in there
over these two bars traded 40 traded 30
traded 80 124 contracts and then moved
away as you start moving away you're
seeing the strong offers come in the six
671 traded there um you know the 299
here you got 360 247 249 here you got
367 209 here you got 216 164 166 so at
this point are you expecting this market
to start rallying back up no i know i've
got overhead resistance coming in here
now this is market generated information
right this is just information you can
just see by looking at a footprint chart
by seeing these point of controls
right i mean look at these deltas very
strong positive delta 622
mark is not going anywhere
328 it's a down bar
349 another down bar
you know this is an easy trade to take
right you just get short anywhere in
here
with your stop just above
this resistance area
and then you just write it giddy up
right you can see as the market just
keeps coming off you're seeing nice
strong
offers trailing it down here's a
here's a buying and balance 212. there's
another buying a balance um 293. look at
this how this market just comes right
down here you see nice strong offers 366
and pretty much single digits here
market just quickly drops all the way
down to this new low does bounce back up
a little bit
sort of comes back up to this 83 area
where you sort of got these point
controls down here one two three four
more or less coming in at 83 and a half
gets within one tick and then drops down
to a new low and just keeps heading on
down
so you know that's a easy way to spot a
market under strong selling pressure is
by watching what's coming in on the
offer is there heavy volume on the offer
side and is it trading it's one thing to
look at a limit order book right look at
your heat map or your book map and see
the size there but you want to see is it
trading because if it's trading there
it's absorbing it all
right i know people like to look at you
know heat maps and book maps and stuff
and and see these levels and
you know the market doesn't really trade
there and so it's not really relevant
but when you see it trading there
right
that's actionable information for you
okay so
again you know today's market was
already under a lot of pressure
and so you know in my opinion these were
easy to see
it gets a little trickier on sort of you
know more quieter days but on days like
today is very obvious just by watching
the order flow so thanks for watching
this be sure to like the video subscribe
to the channel
and you know i'm hoping to get more up
again i'm getting kind of tired of
talking about delta but sometimes it's
just so obvious in in the delta i mean i
could talk about the point of controls
you know migrating down but that's i
mean that should be so obvious to you by
now so thanks everyone and i'll catch
you tomorrow